c'est le match de la jeunesse face à
l'expérience à 14 ans benjamin rhein
actuel meilleur jeune classe et
participe à sa première finale seniors
avec trente ans de plus laurent crépieux
renoue lui avec la deuxième série un
excellent niveau connu il ya quelques
années
mais dès les premiers jeux du match
crépieux s'empare du service du jeune
ryan un premier break qui en amènera
d'autres
malgré un sursaut d'orgueil de belles
accélérations et un débreak à suivre
benjamin raich n'arrivera jamais à
imposer son jeu de fond de court
bon donc un peu de patience parce que
nos précipite assez souvent et peut-être
un peu de puissance je suis pas encore
je suis pas encore à celui sens pour
envoyer ses balles mais après il manque
aussi un peu du jeu c'est pas un peu de
lucidité tactique parce que quand on
veut à dire ça comme ça et si on n'a pas
si on rentre pas tout de suite dans le
match avec une lucidité tactique au
rendez vous c'est plus compliqué
à 45 ans laurent crépieux montre un jeu
varié plus de sérénité malgré quelques
fautes directes une première balle
souvent payantes et surtout des montées
au filet qui déstabilise son adversaire
j'ai un peu joué pour sur ses points
faibles
les balles basses les balles chopées ce
qu'ils sont peut-être plus habitués à
jouer en fait c'est un joueur de fond de
court vous avez réussi à le faire monter
au ciel a joué voilà le fait de monter
casser le rythme un petit peu ça n'a pas
ça n'a pas arrangé je pense la première
manche est remportée 6-1 la deuxième
bien qu'un peu plus disputées se solde
par le même écart laurent crépieux
devient le nouveau champion de
martinique 2e série au terme d'un match
qui a su offrir des échanges de qualité